thank you very much okay now I feel
weird that was my final week as a PhD
student but I'm here talking to you now
because most of that week will look
something like this
let me explain when you vlog this is
what you normally do you look into the
camera you touch your hair you preen you
pout you to some time-lapses you film
yourself working then you take the card
out of your camera put it in your
computer edit the footage together and
then boom next day here's what you do if
you're insanely busy you block your day
you touch your hey you do some time
lapses and then you just kind of do that
day after day off the day off the day
and then weeks later when you finally
get a spare afternoon you take the SD
card out of your camera you put it in
your computer and away you go you're
editing now funnily enough when I was
finishing my PhD I just so happen to be
insanely busy because I was finishing my
PhD and moving out of my home and I
didn't get a chance to take the card out
of my camera for about a month
and when I did well you heard what the
clip sounded like they were all almost
completely unusable and yes before some
smartass and the audience says this my
microphone was turned on but something
happened and I think it was in the last
vlog which incidentally if you haven't
seen yet did you go and check it out
because it involves this in the Seine in
West Country tradition where people
wrestle each other for barrels full of
fire yeah something happened when I was
filming that vlog that busted my
microphone and that was part of the
footage that I didn't offload for about
a month so I didn't realize this at the
time but something that night broke it
can't think what am I have been
but I'm not gonna let that stop me from
telling this story because I know that
my subscribers have been waiting for
this for a long time some of you have
been watching for years for this moment
so it's time to vlog in a different way
[Music]
so here's the situation at the start of
the week
a couple of days before I'd submitted a
complete version of my thesis to my main
supervisor and over the weekend he had
been reading it and annotating it and
potentially finding problems with it on
Monday I had what was meant to be my
final meeting of the PhD with him to go
through those Corrections where if we
found anything particularly wrong then
we had to rethink our plan I mean the
clues in the title things went pretty
much fine after literally looking
through my thesis with a magnifying
glass
he was happy with where it stood apart
from one crucial thing after the meeting
I went back to my office to correct the
first half of the thesis for grammar and
spelling and stupid mistakes that I've
made
[Music]
and that didn't take long at all but
what was a very big problem was
something wrong with two of my plots and
before I can explain what was wrong I
first should explain briefly what my
thesis is about so if you would have
heard this before so I'll keep it quick
basically my thesis is in atmospheric
physics and specifically I was looking
at interaction of the middle atmosphere
that's the stratosphere with the
troposphere the lowest part of the
atmosphere that touches the surface and
I derived a new theory which explained
or attempted to explain observed
coupling that actually observed downward
influence of the stratosphere on the
troposphere and did so using a field
called PV there's plenty of details
about that in previous vlogs the key
thing for this video is that this theory
yielded some predictions and in
particular I was predicting the density
of air as you went higher up in the
atmosphere and also the amount of mass
that was being moved around it was being
fluxed into and out of the polar region
again as a function of height now you
expect those predictions to look pretty
smooth and basically get smaller and
smaller as you go higher up in the
atmosphere but the problem was the two
key pots in this part of the thesis
weren't smooth they looked like this
which is an ideal if you're three days
away from submitting
[Music]
so on Tuesday I motor to try and fix
this problem I did beat last of the city
corrections in grammar and spelling and
re ransom code see the problem was that
normally when you do maths in the
atmosphere you use what's called
isobaric coordinates though these are
coordinates where instead of you're
considering the stuff that's going on
one kilometer up two kilometers up three
kilometers up you're considering at a
thousand hectare Pascal's we know where
the pressure equals a thousand hex
Pascal's and then nine hundred hecto
Pascal's eight hundred hits Pascal's and
you're working on constant pressure
surfaces that is how data is supplied to
you however because of the nature of my
thesis I wasn't interested in that I was
interested in doing stuff on high
coordinates so one kilometer two planets
or three kilometers and I hypothesized
and I really had to bet that this was
correct
i hypothesized that the problem at these
plots was that they were taking the data
on pressure coordinates and then not
converting it correctly to height
coordinates and like I said I had to
really hope this was correct because I
had to do something the following week
that brought me out of Exeter more on
that later so if I didn't submit this
week I was probably had to file for an
extension for my thesis because I would
have needed a lot more time to fix the
problem so I was very stressed out that
morning so stressed out I did what I
normally do which is go get a Coke Zero
and eat some sugar now this did help but
at the end of the day I was still
basically helpless I had to set
something running it that was gonna take
about 12 hours to do and I had basically
just to wait and come in the next day
and see if my hunch was correct and if
so hunky-dory if not world of pain
now I had done a test run over a smaller
little subset of the data rather than
the whole 30 years I think it was like a
month which was promising so I had a
small amount of confidence that I was
gonna be okay and so I took a somewhat
ballsy step in retrospect to fill out
the paperwork that was gonna go with my
thesis if I submitted it and then
[Music]
fortunately I was correct and I came in
the following day and the plots went
from looking like this to looking like
this and then a subsequent pot went from
looking like this to looking like this
which is much nicer and I was quite
relieved about this and with that I had
a thesis which had gone through the
ringer of both supervisors they both
signed off on the scientific content on
how I written it up so I just had to do
one last check come through incidentally
unbelievably nerve-wracking sort of
saying yeah I'm happy with that that's
what's gonna go to my examiner's yeah
okay that's good I can't do any better
than that like that was that was kind of
nerve-wracking and then it was time to
put it on a memory stick and take it to
the printers so I had to get two copies
done for the Biver I had to get one for
each of my examiner's I probably should
have done three so I could have one
because I actually just Princip one out
myself subsequently but it was gonna
take a long time to print there was like
250 pages to print and then 2 copies to
bind so that was gonna take overnight so
I at that point have felt like I left an
atomic bomb in the print shop and I was
gonna go home slightly freaking out and
not really sure how to feel it's not
sure how I feel about it now but I was
excited to go home because I was gonna
be doing something that I've been
itching to do for months
this isn't just any vapor this is thesis
be specific to the role of these
meetings don't shape too
[Music]
you look super cute with the beard
[Music]
[Music]
I can't begin to tell you how happy I
was to get that thing off my face I
actually say as much in this almost
completely silent clip thanks microphone
although some of the styles that I
passed around the way yeah
kind of wish the video wasn't working
either then after that truly momentous
occasion I did what my reflex is to do
in basically any situation I went to my
room and I edited because what else am I
gonna do you know although
coincidentally that night was the office
Christmas party which is miles from
Christmas but I guess these places get
booked up soon so I took my clean face
out on it on its debut to this nice
restaurant where I actually got to sit
amongst all these researchers and feel
like an equal like I was like yeah I've
done what all of you postdocs and the
professor's have done I finally feel
like I kind of belong academically like
I've gone through the fire I mean I'm
quite finished yet again more on that
later but I felt like I was part of the
club now I mean there was still one kind
of important thing I had to do
[Music]
so my friend image and blesser had a
greets film for the vlog she didn't know
the my friend wasn't working so I'm
sorry Imogen your your excellent camera
handling skills or criminally wasted but
she went above and beyond that she got
me a cake with candles in it and
everything and was generally just like
there to push me over the line just in
case I had second thoughts about like
stopping being is June anymore she was
that like no we picked up the two copies
from the princes I almost in a
completely token gesture because it was
fixed at this point checked them through
just to see if there are any mistakes
like if everything was rendered properly
and then I signed my life away and
finalized what I was gonna be submitting
but I wasn't submitting just yet because
I only get to do this once so I did a
stupid little photo shoot there's like a
bit of campus where everybody gets their
photos taken for graduation so naturally
I had to do some pictures there I had to
put something on social media I wanted
to do this for years
[Music]
okay and then I hand it in I mean those
are and then I hand it in there's a five
words that I have been waiting to say on
this blog just so long I have to admit I
was pretty nervous because you know what
I hadn't done this before so I didn't I
wanted to make sure I was doing it right
and suddenly that was this moment when I
walked away from the desk and I had like
a little receipt saying you know we've
got your thesis that's all good and
there was this moment when I was like
it's it's actually done I don't know I
feel like imaging you gonna go and do
some shots
I should probably do some shots there's
nothing really I want to simply I do
want to see my girlfriend then after
submitting I had to go to the office
because I wanted to say to everybody you
know I did it finally submitted and had
to take part in a little office
tradition that's been going on for a
while where anybody that submits a paper
that gets like a successful submission
through into an academic journal we have
a little bottle of vodka in the in the
office and because the thesis is worth
more than a paper I had to do two shots
of vodka at like 10 a.m. so that was a
fun walk home campus and then much as I
wish I could tell you that I then had
this glitzy glamorous afternoon rollers
like yeah I'm a rock star
I finally submitted my thesis I walked
home I call my mum and dad because I
loved them very much and I knew they
wanted to hear I called my girlfriend
and I won't have any had a pizza not
rock star
but all oh boy did I feel kiss and then
after that I edited because of course
I would I mean if you've watched any my
vlog do you know me by now I had the
last of the ready meals that I bought in
preparation for the lot final stretch of
my thesis just I guess for old times
sake at time I was like I don't know I
just felt like one I also picked up my
physical copy of the chapel choir CD
which I designed as you saw a couple of
vlogs ago which was very pleased with
and then I packed because I was going
off to Cambridge the following day
well you heard about that in a second
because between me packing and me going
I may have gone out for a few drinks
with with Chapel Choir friends but
unfortunately I am I didn't even try and
vlog that morning after day
[Music]
for some reason I don't remember doing
very much on that day I basically just
dragged myself to the train station and
got on a train to Cambridge to see pixel
girl for the first time since submitting
and her house is very very noisy dog and
for readers of the wiki cast the house
is wonderful cat
[Music]
[Music]
and then I spent what I think is a
well-deserved chill weekend not doing
very much at all I don't actually think
I've shown Cambridge in the vlog before
obviously going to Oxford
there's my degree there obviously
there's a certain lab emnity towards
Cambridge but you know as a city I guess
it's it's alright I did make use of the
excellent bookshop heifers in Cambridge
though although the last time I was in
that I impulse bought like four or five
books so I literally had to restrain
myself as I helped pick so go get a book
and then when we went around the
University shop because actually maybe
you don't know for those of you who
didn't go to Oxford or Cambridge you get
stash that is things like jumpers and
scarves and things like that that are
specific to your college not just the
University so we went to get pixel girls
one she's at hominin college so we went
to the shop and I fortunately didn't
have anything that was right for
Hamilton but I did get to meet one of
you guys a subscriber
was there who came up and was like
apologetically I'm sorry I went to
Cambridge no like way I was that was
chose lovely lovely to meet you and then
speaking of Homerton we went there and
did some work and I was basically
catching up on being human being again
because right up until the moment when I
was submitting I was just so laser
focused on getting this thesis done that
I wasn't paying attention to anything
else so email was a pie order and also
things like Facebook messages and
messages from friends being like did you
die and I had to be like oh god this is
two months old I'm so so sorry so I was
I was basically catching up on on yeah
being human being whilst pixel girl
actually did you know her proper
coursework before
on Sunday we went and got fo fou not
quite sure how to pronounce it the
Vietnamese noodle soup gotta say this
place in Cambridge absolutely ace so not
a paid endorsement other thing but if
you're in Cambridge pretty good it's
faux it's on what street are we on
William Street what Wiener Street and
then after that we basically wander
around Cambridge for a bit and did some
shopping and I mean I did warn you we
didn't do very much and went back to ha
Martin again before I got a very late
bus to Heathrow Airport because as I
mentioned earlier I had to leave Exeter
because I've been bought a plane ticket
to go to New York for a week by YouTube
but that's a story for the next vlog
which unfortunately also has this audio
problem but I think is sufficiently
interesting that you're gonna want to
tune in for that but before I go I do
want to say a couple of things one to
everyone who's saying oh so you're
doctor now huh
not yet I still have to do my viber
which is my final boss of Education I
had to defend my research in an exam
that can last I mean there isn't
actually enough a time limit it could
take all day it's probably me a couple
of hours in me sat in the room with my
thesis and talking to two world leading
academics about what I've been up to and
trying to justify that it's worth giving
me the title of doctor so not a doctor
yet
- thank you to everyone who's been
watching this vlog over the past year
I've actually bit more than a year now I
have been incredibly lucky to have an
engaged audience that I I just know has
been behind me 100% like if I'm having a
tough time you've always been there to
lift me up and keep my motivation going
I know that a lot of you in the comments
say that I motivate you with my work
ethic or whatever you guys motivate me
to keep working knowing that I have you
is like as so cliche but like as a
YouTube family
you know like
I feel like you've got my back and
sharing in all the victories like when I
fix my code and you know yeah helping me
win things that are tough you guys
really really helped me over the past
year in a bit so thank you to those of
you who have been watching and also
thank you to those of you who've been
watching for even longer some of you
been watching since I was at Oxford as
an undergrad I recognize your names in
the comments I really do and I
appreciate so much the fact that you've
got invested in this and this this
journey that I've got on so thank you
for for being there for me three a
special shout out has to go to pixel
girl because she's been wonderful and
she's gonna kill me for putting this in
the video but yeah she's great I
wouldn't been able to do this without
her in particular yeah I love you and
then lastly for thank you for watching I
realized this has been a somewhat
unconventional vlog it's not exactly
like everything else in the series but
as I said at the start you guys have
been waiting for this for as long as I
have nearly so I had to tell this story
so thank you for watching the video and
putting up with this kind of width set
up if you did enjoy it give it a like
comment below if you'd like to see more
like this hit the subscribe button
because as I mentioned in a previous
video I'm gonna be doing a lot more
videos now I'm gonna be trying to do two
a week so cool that's a lot of work I
thought PhD was tough thank you for
watching and I'll see you next time
we did it I'm gonna roll myself up in a
big ball and
[Music]
[Music]